cyclone batsiray slammed into
madagascar's eastern coastline with
heavy rains and wind speeds of 165
kilometers per hour
flooding roads and leaving several
houses completely submerged
tens of thousands of people have been
displaced
it was early morning we were still
sleeping our landlord came to tell us
that water was rising we got up to move
the furniture all while the water
continued to rise
the house started cracking some of our
furniture was still upstairs and the
crack started to get worse
some of our belongings have been
destroyed
residents use tree branches to measure
the depth of the floods
the damage compounded by the destruction
left by another cyclone two weeks
earlier
which killed dozens and displaced 130
thousand people
the damage is big the wind was very
strong and even if people took care to
protect their belongings there had been
a lot of damage
aid disease have prepared food to
distribute to those in need with u.n
evacuation flights on standby
children and worried parents fill the
floors of this local evacuation center
we live on the hill on the edge of a
cliff the wind was strong but our house
is also strong
early in the morning there was a
landslide to be safe the head of the
neighborhood told us to go to the
evacuation center that's why we're here
madagascar has recently suffered drought
another country hit by extreme weather
as a result of climate change
jillian wolf al jazeera